good morning believe nation today's
messages figure out what you really want
over to you tom delonge I think I
learned over the past handful of years
that what I really enjoyed about a band
wasn't being on stage it was just the
idea there's I'm involved somehow and
leading a group of people to feel
something at the same time I thought
that was really cool that's what I kind
of dissect it I was because I was doing
a lot of things doing a lot of things I
I was equally interested in a lot of
different things besides just music um
and so a lot of people are wondering why
would you not want to be on a big stage
doing all this stuff and I I just uh
call do I Instagram this am I supposed
to go on Instagram and tell you all this
thing all these things that I feel about
you know I don't you know um and but
really what it boils down to is I I have
a pretty wild imagination and I have a
few set of skills that I've developed
not only inspiring artists or leading
people or putting business models to
things or being entrepreneurial and and
also understanding i'm not really good
at any one thing but i'm decently good
at a bunch of different things and I
kind of figure I said you know it might
be a really good place for me to sit in
the middle of a bunch of artists that
come together that that can do something
a bit more revolutionary than want each
artist doing one thing on their own yeah
and um that's where I came from I think
a lot of entrepreneurs feel stuck a lot
of entrepreneurs feel boxed in you may
be really good at something like graphic
design your video production or
consulting or singing or whatever and
you started this business but you feel
like there's something more right you
feel like I mean I could do a lot more
with my talents for my interest but I
just don't know quite what it is and a
lot of entrepreneurs don't explore that
and they just stay in that box that you
know you've designed
yourself there's nobody telling you you
have to stay in that box you're an
entrepreneur you don't have a box you
can do whatever you want but a lot of
people don't have the courage to sneak
outside and it starts with self
awareness so in tom delonge his case he
understood that being part of the bang
was something that he was good at but
not necessarily what he wanted to do
because his skills and what really he
was passionate about was leading the
group of people to feel something and
that can be applied in a lot of
different areas and that allowed him to
step up that allowed him to step up to
do something with more purpose and more
passion more excitement David hand in
just being a part of a bang and so I
think just that awareness is
super-important understanding if you're
not satisfied with your business right
now and thus you know me not me because
you have enough customers coming in or
there may be a host of other issues that
you're facing your company but the work
like do you enjoy the work I like making
these youtube videos i look forward to
wednesday afternoon why get in front of
my camera I have Jason come and help me
and I'm filming videos I like the work
you know do you like your work and if
you don't then this mean you have to
abandon it completely and just go off on
some crazy you know right to discover
yourself but you need at least spend
some time to figure out what it is that
you truly want what it is that really
makes you come alive and dedicating some
of your energy towards that because
otherwise you're going to get stuck in
that same box for the rest of your life
and never hitting your ceiling never
hitting your full potential never
hitting what you could do with the
impact that you could have because
instead of chasing what you really want
to do but you're really good at really
makes you come alive you're stuck inside
your box so figure out what you really
want so the question that today is do
you feel stuck in what you're doing is
the work still making you come alive or
not be honest I'm really curious to find
out leave in the comments below and I'll
join the discussion another quick favor
to ask my goal is to get to a million
subscribers on this channel so anything
you can do think of to help spread the
word about this video share with friends
let people know about it I really really
really really appreciate it thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot a vinspresso